holy crap it's you guys you guys are the
Avengers of YouTube right we are yeah
you guys inspire people we do what do
you idiots do it when the Avengers yeah
you too
no you guys are movie reviewers I'm the
director of shield no oh the you
reviewers 2013 why do you have an
eyepatch because I had eye surgery go
get dressed
get changed we got to shoot this okay
I'm serious
welcome to the third annual new
reviewers Movie Awards with your host
Jerry job and straight out
well Christian in March
now
Ward's welcome to the 2013 you reviewers
movie awards we're your hosts I'm Jeremy
Jones these are the schmoes Thank You
Jeremy
I'm Kristian harloff and it's very
exciting to be back for year 3 it's such
an event this year that even Ellis and I
got dressed up I'm Marc Ellison I was
told we go to the Olive Garden but this
is just as good and the best part is the
you reviewers movie awards has come back
home where it belongs on our channels on
my channel on their channel yeah if you
don't know how this award show works
basically what it is the YouTube movie
reviewing community comes together and
we vote and nominate and hopefully you
guys enjoy it we're ready to go we are
seconds away from the results of what
the best movie and the worst stink piles
of 2012 or even cooler than that is that
all the fans of all these different
shows can come together and celebrate
everything we love about the talking
pictures it's awesome tacular well no
that's mine dude yes you are Jeremy
let's just get this thing rolling all
right first category is Best Supporting
Actor and here to present Best
Supporting Actor is Erik Stifler and the
crew from pretty much get your black and
white and cigarettes ready and take it
away boys hello I am Erik I'm Jake and
I'm Mai and we are pretty much it it's a
pun because we end all of our videos
with and that's pretty much it yeah we
are very excited and grateful to have
been invited back to the you reviewers
Awards to present you reviewers 2013
let's cut to the chase oh we've got to
present Best Supporting Actor whoo
that's important the nominees are Robert
DeNiro silver linings playbook okay
Christoph Waltz from Django Unchained
okay Leonardo DiCaprio from Django
Unchained I say one Philip Seymour
Hoffman from can I say one say um can I
say Javier Bardem from Skyfall I can't
say anything if you fail you fail we
gave and the winner is were you just
keeping that in your shirt I've had it
in their shirt for about a month the
winner is
Christoph Waltz all right all right cool
but congratulations to Christoph Waltz I
did think he was great I was just hoping
for Leo and thank you very much for
having us on the new reviewers Awards
again yeah that's pretty much that's our
tagline
that's like I told you earlier you get
to the seven any chance to do a German
accent
I want to shark Leo didn't get more love
though see this indication point though
is if you're supporting actor in a movie
in the same year that Christoph Waltz is
a supporting actor in the movie it's not
your year give it to him maybe next time
good point all right I'm gonna get this
animal out of here he's sweating
breadstix that's cool I got flick pic
we're gonna bring him in here we're
gonna do some stuff sounds good flick
how you doing welcome to the studio in
studio in person nice to meet you man
it's great to be here nice to meet you
too and you know looking at you right
now I felt a little bit underdressed
right I feel overdressed it's not weird
I guess anything with Robin on its a
fashion statement and I love fashion
statements our next presenters are a duo
there are Year reviewers tradition
they're always bringing class to the
show and that is gabon dad Family Values
at their best and they're presenting
best supporting actress supporting us
stories thanks a lot guys
it's GAD from gab and dad drilled to be
announcing for the you reviewers the
category Best Supporting Actress and the
nominees are Sally Field for Lincoln
Judi Dench Skyfall and Hathaway Lim is
our habla Amy Adams the master and Emily
Blunt looper and now often dad in a
special location to announce the winner
that Missy Kat dad here in a special
location in Paris France with the Eiffel
Tower behind me I'm here to announce the
winner in the Best Supporting Actress
category and the winner is
and Hathaway for Leamas Club
Missy lot of wha
back to you guys Anne Hathaway holy and
that's the thing as the Sheep completely
blew the field away
Sally Field away there's still ha though
yeah I've done every one of them I'd hit
that
Sally feels even Janet even Judi Dench
alright flick thanks a lot for coming
out I really appreciate it I love
meeting your man we're gonna bring the
schmoes back in here for best script and
cruise stuntman it's a party in here
thanks guys the schmoes are back with
you in a very special guest mr. Jack
Reacher of come on introduce the guy
like he should be introduced this is
Chris stuckman you know his channel he's
tall he's thought about I get it but
stuckman stuckman eyes the whole thing I
could bring anything and sorry alright
alright alright we're talking about the
best script of the year guys get it
together not the scripts that were made
with the best dialogue the best stories
the most interesting characters more
than nomination well I apologize for
Peter Dinklage here there's a lot of
nominations and there's a good presenter
as well the presenter this year is
Travis Ross
take it away Travis hey kids how you
boys doing looks like me and Vincent
caught you at breakfast sorry about that
now would you please tell me the
nominations for best script what what do
you know movie I ever heard of what say
what again
come on say what again I dare you I
double dare ya now what are the
nominations for best scripts Argo go on
silver linings playbook looper Seven
Psychopaths Django Unchained and the
winner
what and the winner is
Django Unchained what a rocker Django
Unchained when you can be a normal
height now I know you love the script
Chris what do you think Django Unchained
is the one I wanted to win it was the
best script of the year best dialog best
characters very dynamic yeah I mean it's
Tarantino the guy it to me is one of the
best writers out there very happy you
got the win can I just say it what I
must break you
ass thank you gentlemen now we're on to
one of my favorite categories I don't
know you know I have love for the
animations out there with all the
nominees this year this is this is my
category this is where I breathe this is
home we got Tom Channel - presenting
best animation what's going on everybody
I really hope you are enjoying the u're
viewers Movie Awards thus far anyway
today I am here to present to you the
Award for Best Animated Feature Film and
it's an honour of distinct honor so
let's get to the nominees and then I
will announce the winner first we have
brave the animated film that shows
Katniss before she was recruited by the
CIA and given a dialect coach and then
gets put undercover in district 12 to
take down and participate in the Hunger
Games yeah you didn't see that during
break did you but I saw that underlying
message then you have ParaNorman -
stop-motion animated film that was
clearly not meant for kids then you have
pirates the band of misfits another
stop-motion animated film which contains
comedy that probably went over every
little kid's head but they were kind of
entertained by all the big colors and
the physical humor probably so there's
that then you have Frankenweenie Tim
Burton's twisted version of Frankenstein
but with a dog but with a dog then you
have record Ralph which confirms for
everybody what we think john c reilly
would look like as an animated character
and also it made for a pretty goddamn
entertaining movie and in this envelope
i have the winner of this category so
without further ado let's announce the
winner for Best Animated movie the
winner is
rekka drought Wow wreck-it Ralph winning
in a landslide my video game people out
there got my back and to celebrate that
fact I bring you all of Mario and Luigi
easy sonic how's your Sega Genesis Sega
CDs one of the most underrated systems
of all time easy I'm still working on
Gameboy but I want to thank everybody
for watching episode 1 of the 2013 you
reviewers Awards be sure to subscribe to
my channel be sure to subscribe to their
Channel yeah and that's where you can
find episode 2 of the reviewers Awards
for this year check it out
you got to do the punch ya do it
you guys want to punch it it's awesome
tacular that's mine